the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
great to be back in studio I have a
couple of very interesting stories from
my trip to Las Vegas last week and I
want to leave plenty of time for that
but I do want to quickly mention that
President Trump has decided to release a
whole bunch of documents of previously
classified documents related to the John
F Kennedy assassination in 1963 and we
are approaching the 54 year anniversary
of that I don't know there's a
particular meaning to 54 years but
anyway we're approaching that and I
there are people who are reacting very
strongly to this news from Donald Trump
and that now we're really trump is
really gonna enable us to find out the
truth of that I think it's mostly a lot
about nothing I think a lot of the
documents just because something is
being released doesn't mean it will be
unredacted and I don't expect much from
this well there's a lot of people in the
intelligence agencies who don't want him
to release those documents and I guess
there are thousands of them but
apparently they mostly have to do with
Lee Harvey Oswald's trip to Mexico City
apparently he met with a lot of Soviet
and Cuban spies while he was there and
may have discussed the planning of the
assassination so I don't think we're
gonna find out about about any second
shooters I mean that stuff no
interesting I wouldn't expect any major
revelations and I was actually pitched
this woman
Judith very Baker we interviewed her I
guess at this point it's been a couple
years ago and she was allegedly Lee
Harvey Oswald's lover and she claims
that he was totally innocent or framed
or something like that and I had her on
because I thought it would be
interesting but the reaction from the
audience was David this is a mentally
ill woman and you're taking advantage of
someone who clearly needs mental health
help and she was recently reached to us
because of this and I was straight up
with the Booker I said listen I do find
it kind of interesting but people
emailed me and they were angry saying I
was taking advantage of someone who
really should be getting treatment and
the Booker didn't acknowledge believing
the same thing she
just said thanks for letting me know I
won't pitch her again I've actually seen
her interviewed on a number of other
different platforms as well and I wonder
if she would promote this idea that it
was actually Ted Cruz's father who
killed Jenny yeah she didn't mention
that last time but that that would
become as a surprise to me if she
shifted to that idea so anyway well I'll
look at the documents but I'm not really
expecting to see anything particularly
interesting okay so two stories from my
trip to Las Vegas I was in Las Vegas
broadcasting from Vegas last week from
the masked courts made perfect
conference it's a conference organized
by the law firm of Mike Papantonio
fellow talk-show host and friend of the
David Pakman show and the entertainment
for this conference was scheduled to be
and was I mean when I say scheduled to
be it implies it didn't happen
illusionist magician stuntman David
Blaine okay now I've always found David
Blaine to be cuckoo for cocoa puffs I
mean just a bizarre dude but I did enjoy
some of his tricks and stunts although
I've never much cared for like hanging
upside down for 10 days while doing
who-knows-what I don't really care about
that stuff but I do think that guys are
pretty good illusionist and magician so
I was actually excited to see him I
don't know if you're a fan of his yeah
and he tried to break the record for
longest amount of time holding his
breath under water yes so much of an
illusion though it's just a skill you
have to build I guess you build it up
yeah over time so he was scheduled to be
the entertainment on Thursday evening
around 2:00 p.m. Vegas time on that same
day news breaks that David Blaine has
been accused of rape allegedly a rape
that took place in 2004 and the details
that were available online were
relatively specific now of course these
were allegations allegations that were
completely denied by Blaine and his
representatives but at the conference we
were all talking so if you've invited
him here and clearly he charges a lot of
money to do these private performances
do you cancel but you probably still
have to pay the guy because you have a
contract because it would look bad at
the same time you know a lot of defense
attorneys at that conference who would
be the first to say hey innocent until
proven guilty these are merely
allegations would it be a pro
for Blaine to say given the controversy
I'm not going to do the performance not
really so it was this weird thing were
six hours before the performance the
guys accused of rape international news
and he ended up doing the performance I
mean he showed up obviously did not
mention it in any ways him in any way
that you could see I don't know I mean
he always kind of seems like he's
annoyed with everybody and not really
that pleased to be there so that was you
know it wasn't really any different that
was just his demeanor so a very weird
situation and I was thinking if I was
running the conference what would I do
I think you kind of have to just allow
the performance to happen because again
he's not been proven guilty of anything
although there are lots of times when
just based on accusations people are not
allowed to participate in certain
activities
I honestly don't know I mean if you were
running that conference and let's say I
mean let's assume he was getting paid a
hundred grand for a private performance
I have no idea how much it was what do
you do if six hours before this guy you
planned that a year in advance right six
hours before this guy's accused of rape
do you let him perform or do you not I
think you have to let him perform I mean
it's it's an allegation and you have to
take every allegation seriously it's not
like he's been convicted of anything I
think you're gonna have to go along with
this idea of innocent until proven
guilty I mean maybe it would be
different if there was a whole slew of
allegations like a bunch of women came
forward yeah together I think that you
might have to treat differently just one
from what 15 years ago 13 years ago
sometime matters so much but it's
important to weigh all these things I
guess at the same time why is it more
serious if it's multiple accusations
right are you are we saying if only one
woman was raped it's not a big I jump
and it just seems as if the accusations
might be more credible I guess yes but
again it implies that this one is not
credible which I don't want I don't want
to do either you know I don't know in
any case he did the performance and it
was pretty good I actually am most
interested in the card stuff that he
does he like ate a woman's wineglass
yeah and I don't really care about that
I am curious how he does it he just ate
the woman's glass but I I'm not it
sounds crazy I'm not that impressed by
that he did the thing where he pierced
his arm with an ice pick and I've seen
him do that before like in front of Neil
deGrasse Tyson he did it through his
hand
I'm curious how he does it but I don't
find it that compelling I'm most and he
also sewed his mouth shut with needle
and thread I mean it was not saying yeah
if it's like I'm regurgitate frogs too
that's another one someone mentioned
that I did I do not care about stuff
like that I really think it's it's not
interesting I don't know if you're into
those I think it's fascinating I think I
should have attended instead of you I I
and a lot of people in there were
cringing but the card tricks I actually
find to be the most interesting thing
anyway that's David Blaine here's the
other story um we have a lot of pilots
in the audience so I'm not going to say
what airline this took place on but I
was flying home from Las Vegas to Boston
and you know how there are these exit
rows on planes that are a sort of near
or above the wing and those are rows
where typically there's more legroom
because it's an evacuation row where in
the event of an emergency you open these
over-wing exits and people can leave the
plane evacuate the plane through those
exits so initially the airlines did not
charge more for those seats but now that
those seats have more leg room even
though often the seats don't recline
they consider it like a premium seat
depending on the airline you pay
anywhere from 25 to a hundred bucks to
sit in the exit row because you've got
more legroom okay however FAA
regulations require that the flight
attendants check with the people sitting
in exit rows and make sure that they're
aware that they're in an exit row that
they're aware that they would be
expected to help in the event of an
evacuation and have them verbally
confirm that they're willing to do so
and and of course this also helps you
you confirm that they understand what
you're talking to them about I was about
to board the plane and right in front of
me there is a woman with flying with her
father her father was elderly could have
been in his 80s could have been in his
90s the woman was maybe between 50 and
60 years old something like that and as
they are checking in the gate agent
scans the ticket and of course it pops
up on her screen this is an exit row so
she says first to the woman you're
seated in an exit row I need you to
verbally confirm that you're willing and
able to help in the event of an
emergency evacuation and the woman says
yes I am and then this guy comes up the
woman's father and said and the gate
agent says
sir you're seated in an exit row I want
to make sure that you are able and
willing and able to help people evacuate
and the guy doesn't say a word and he
smirks and he looks at his daughter so
right away it's okay
does this guy understand what's going on
and the woman says dad they're asking
you a question and he says they are the
one who says dad you've got to say yes
and then the gate agent wants to try to
see if this is gonna be considered a guy
being coached or whether he really
understands just sir I need you to tell
me yes or no are you willing and able to
help people through the exit row in the
event of an evacuation and the guy says
huh and looks at the at his daughter
this went on for about it felt like five
minutes but it was probably 30 seconds
and eventually the guy goes yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay so he wasn't playing
coy or anything he probably just didn't
understand it seemed as though he
probably had some level of dementia or
cognitive decline from age so the woman
looks pretty concerned but they let the
guy on the plane and I was seated far
enough up whereas as people were coming
in the gate agent comes in and the
flight attendants say listen we noticed
the guy who's in an exit row
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo and I know right
away they also noticed that this guy is
in an exit row
he doesn't seem particularly physically
equipped to help with an evacuation it's
unclear cognitively where he is and the
gate agent lies the gate agent says no I
asked him whether he was able to help
and when he understood the question he
fully repeated it back to me and said
yes I am able and willing to help total
lie
all the guy did was start repeating yeah
yeah yeah and the flight attendants
looked at each other and after the gate
agent left the plane they said what do
you think I don't know I mean it is at
our discretion but she said he
understood now at this point I'm saying
hold on a second that was a lie do I
have a responsibility as a passenger who
saw what took place to say hey guys that
gate agent lied to you that guy is not
equipped and ultimately I realized if I
do that this plane is getting delayed
this is going to be a major problem
you're a bad guy I may be
bad guy and ultimately what I told
myself and I don't know if this is crazy
and there's pilots in the audience who
can tell me if we get to the point where
we're evacuating through the exit row
over-wing exits I don't know that that
one out of the six people who will be in
the exit rows are really going to be the
make-or-break and maybe that's a stupid
way to rationalize it but I said nothing
unfortunately we had a safe flight back
to Boston yeah it is pretty disturbing
because you should understand that this
guy's not going to be able to help in
the case of an emergency even if he says
that he's willing and able to do so yeah
because it's not clear physically
capable even if that's exactly what the
flight attendants were saying which is
regardless of whether he was coached in
his answer it doesn't seem that he would
be physically able to actually help but
ultimately they said they rolled their
eyes and said well we're not gonna do
anything about it so had he said no
wouldn't they just switch the man and
his daughter out with two other people
right but I guess maybe you lose that
little extra area because it was a very
intuition that his daughter was trying
to make it just a very simple say yes
dad because she wanted to sit in the
exit row with the extra legroom of
course that's why it is because
otherwise every seats the same who cares
but it's not they have an extra three
inches of legroom or whatever so anyway
let me know what would you have done if
you're a pilot right in did I do the
right thing did I do the wrong thing and
we will maybe follow up
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]